Sufism or tasaw wolf has become famous
around the world for its various
artistic Expressions art music and
perhaps most of all poetry
the Persian Sufi jalaladin Rumi is
immensely popular in many parts of
Europe and North America today and was
for a while the best-selling poet in the
U.S
other Persian poets have also been
referenced numerous times in pop
cultures such as Hafiz Sadi and atar
just to mention a few
however for some reason Arabic Sufi
poetry has not received the same amount
of Love even though it is equally as
important and significant for the
history of Sufism and Sufi poetry the
Persian poets deserve all the love that
they get of course but it's still
worthwhile to explore the incredibly
beautiful and vast tradition of Arabic
soupy poetry which include many
significant figures like IBN Arabi IBN
and one of my personal favorites about
Hassani
true
[Music]
[Applause]
is one of the most significant and most
renowned mystical poets in the Arabic
language and his poems and songs are
still sung in Sufi Gatherings across
North Africa his literary output is vast
and very influential and he is even
sometimes been referred to as the urumi
of the West
despite this not a lot of people around
the world know about him and certainly
not as much as they know about someone
like Rumi for example and not a lot of
academic study has been dedicated to him
or his Works hopefully this is about to
change and I hope this episode will
contribute to more knowledge about this
fascinating figure as Church Daddy was
born in the year 1212 in Spain and in
particular in a small Village near
Granada called Sistar where he gets his
nisbah or name from we are thus dealing
with another 13th century figure that
period which brought some of the most
significant philosophers and Mystics in
history maybe he would have been better
known had he not had to compete with so
many other great figures of his day
Reports say that he came from a rather
well-off aristocratic family perhaps
connected to the ruling Elite but at
some point in his adult life as he was
working as a traveling Merchant he
instead turned to the Sufi way an
ascetic life on the mystical path this
is a common Trope among many similar
figures but it's quite possibly true the
chronicler IBN khatib writes about sure
study that quote he came from a line of
emirs and joined the ranks of the poor
indeed sure study became a kind of
wandering Sufi and he traveled around
al-andalus and the Maghrib which is
Western North Africa it seems that he
became particularly connected with the
tariqah or Sufi order of the famous 12th
century Mystic Abu madyan through his
followers in Tunisia and Algeria and
that sure study's path in particular was
one of relatively extreme asceticism and
poverty throughout his life and in his
writings he would always put an emphasis
on the concept of tajirid of stripping
bear literally or stripping oneself of
all attachment to worldly things
identities and to the self or ego
indeed later in his life when he was a
respected Sufi Master he would be
referred to as the Imam
leader of the withdrawn sufis literally
those who strip away
he renounced most worldly things and
became famous among other things for
wearing the the patch cloak of Sufi
poverty as well as serving and giving to
the poor which is a theme that we will
return to later on he was a well-learned
and educated man though as we can
clearly see in his writings he learned
all the religious Sciences growing up he
knew the Quran the Hadith and Islamic
law of which he was a kind of expert
actually at one point it was even
offered the position of chief judge in
Libya in the city of Tripoli but turned
it down in a very dramatic fashion by
shaving off his beard and eyebrows
leading to accusations of Madness
this very strong reluctance of study to
have any association with worldly power
and its jurists is another theme that
will come back later in the discussion
but it is in 1248 when he would have
been around 35 years old that his life
and Legacy would be significantly
altered as he encountered the very
charismatic and controversial Mystic
philosopher IBN sabahin
this initial meeting took place in bhuji
in modern Algeria where IBN sabaain is
thought to have uttered the completely
amazing words quote if it is Paradise
you desire go withyan which was the
founder of the tariqah that church that
it was following at the time if it is
the master of paradise that you desire
then let's begin
which is I'll say it again just a
completely badass thing to say and
naturally of course you study from that
moment on became a devoted disciple of
IBN Sabine for the rest of his life IBN
sabahin is an incredibly fascinating
figure and he is also controversial for
his seemingly monistic almost non-dual
mystical philosophy and interpretation
of Islam and and the world and that is
also because of his connection to IBN
sabaim that was also eventually somewhat
of a controversial figure at least in
certain circles The 14th Century hanbali
theologian IBN taimiya very famously
wrote attacks against certain figures
primarily sufis whose ideas he
considered to be unacceptable IBN Arabi
was included in this attack who is
doctrine of was deemed heretical in the
same breath though Urban tymia also
turns to IBN sabaain and his followers
which included Ashish Devi and deems
them to be even worse than IBN happy
they are the worst of the worst in other
words
makes a similar division where the
school of IBN Arabi while still being
suspect and dangerous are at least not
as Extreme as the followers of IBN
sabaim
this is mostly due to the characteristic
mystical philosophy that they adhere to
one that was often referred to
aslaka absolutes Unity or absolute
Oneness
this probably reminds you of the famous
the unity of being ascribed to IBN
arabian's followers and the two ideas
are similar in many ways reality is
ultimately one and there is nothing in
existence but God who is the real al-haq
itself
however IBN sabahin and his followers
were a bit more radical in their
expression of this idea and the
conclusions that they drew from it
whereas IBN Arabi viewed the world as
relatively real the world is the
reflection and manifestation of God's
infinite attributes and he always
maintains a certain difference between
the two and that is God and Creation in
a certain sense IBN sabahin and his
school saw the world as a complete
illusion there is only God nothing else
God alone and nothing else
in a characteristic section IBN sabahin
writes quote I was first led to say I
have never seen a thing without seeing
God behind it
then to say which is closer to the truth
I have never seen a thing without seeing
God with it
then finally to say I have never seen a
thing without seeing God before it
now I can only say he he he
this may seem radical and it kind of is
in some ways even someone like IBN Arabi
would rarely Express his ideas about
Oneness in such direct and radical ways
but being a student of IBN a sure study
also expresses himself in his poems and
his writings in similarly
strong and and maybe even radical ways
now to understand the doctrines of these
figures and their relationship to the
larger Islamic intellectual world and
tradition we need of course to consider
their environment Ashish Delhi came from
the Islamic West from al-andalus which
is modern Spain this Western world
including the Maghrib and the Islamic
East had developed somewhat distinct
mystical Traditions even though they
were in contact of course
by the 12th and 13th centuries Sufism
quote unquote had entered the Western
World and people like sure study and IBN
sabayin can rightly be called sufis in a
sense we should also understand that
they are inheritors to a unique mystical
tradition that developed in the West in
particular nowadays we tend to use the
word Sufism to refer to all this right
any form of Islamic mysticism is Sufism
but in the earlier periods Sufism or a
tasaw wolf was primarily associated with
the mystical developments that took
place in the central Islamic land such
as in Baghdad they were concerned with
these psychological development of the
Soul on the journey towards intimacy
with God through direct mystical
knowledge of him called marifa now again
this stuff was present in the west as
well but we also see a unique form of
quote-unquote mysticism developing here
usually traced back to the fascinating
10th Century Mystic philosopher IBN
masara he and his followers were more
speculatively inclined influenced by
neoplatonic ideas and developed complex
cosmological and metaphysical systems
into which mystical practice played in
particular these Mystics were concerned
with a concept called meaning
contemplation as well as something
called ibra of crossing over literally
from this mundane realm to the other
Divine realm through contemplation of
the science in nature the Quran of
nature which was the manifestation of
the Divine attributes by the 12th
century these ideas were further
represented and developed by figures
like IBN barajan and IBN Arif who in
turn would have a major influence on the
great Mystics of the 13th century in a
way you could say that the Great Western
Sufi Mystics of the 13th century such as
kinda represent the culmination of that
culture they take both the ideas and
practices of Eastern Sufism and marry it
with the native speculative mystical
Traditions as well as other
philosophical movements to create truly
fascinating and influential ideas one
central idea that is quite unique to
this particular group of Mystics is an
emphasis on the concept of
realization or verification
indeed to further complicate our
categories when we read people like IBN
Arabi ortari we find them dividing
people into groups like sufis and
gnostics arifun the people of blame or
the malamatia and
people of verification or verifiers or
realizers maybe all these being
different categories of Mystics even
though the category is often overlap of
course and to assure study the muhakeun
the people of turkey or verification are
the top of the latter it is this group
that he sees himself as belonging to
now again we shouldn't take these
categories too seriously as we can still
call Sufi and he would probably himself
have recognized himself as part of the
tradition of tasaw wolf but we should
rather see it as different stages or
levels or maybe approaches to reaching
God the idea of Tahir seems to have been
developed from the earlier Western idea
of ethibar or of contemplation and ibra
crossing over but developed into a
rather New Concept of the utmost
experienced or realization of the
Oneness of God a true realization of the
fact that there is only God God is all
and all else is illusion a shift study
is mostly famous for his poetry which
we'll return to when we find this
monistic or non-dualistic Vision there
too but it becomes perhaps especially
clear in some of his prose writings in
his treat is called resale
talks about three categories of people
there is theologians those ashadi
theologians who reach knowledge of God
through rational proof and argumentation
secondly there is sufis who reach
knowledge of God through direct
experience and see that everything comes
from God
and lastly the highest form in some way
are the verifiers
who reached the highest station seeing
reality for what it truly is which is
the Oneness of God
these scholar Yusuf Castlewood writes
quotes
while the Sufi sees the created realm as
a dim Shadow or a silhouette the
realizer experiences a complete
absorption in direct and unitive
knowledge of God and the separative
realm of other than God is extinguished
the realizer is not a monist in the
sense of believing that God and creation
form an ontological unitary whole with
one underlying ultimate substance rather
the realizer verifies the Bold assertion
that creation does not exist at all it
is not a separate entity from God the
realizer affirms a non-dualist truth and
denies the very existence of the sufi's
empty tents of material creation
God is Not veiled by anything and the
category of other than God is illusory
and non-existent
and quote the realizer is both the
perceived and the perceiver the subject
and object of awareness he is unaware of
his awareness and is no longer aware of
himself since his awareness is none
other than gods
we shouldn't see this as some
exclusionary idea though the borders
between these categories are not very
rigid and they are not exclusive from
each other so for example who definitely
saw himself as a realizer or a verifier
he also probably saw himself as a Sufi
to some degree and in terms of theology
he followed the ashadi School of
Theology so in some sense he belongs to
all of these categories but what he's
doing here is rather describing a kind
of Well a different levels of
realization in a sense so he isn't
saying that the other groups the
theologians and the sufis are wrong in
any way it's it's different levels of
understanding reality of understanding
god with the verifiers OR realizers at
the top who can see reality for what it
truly is all these different levels of
understanding have their place for
certain groups of people but that the
verifiers or realizers are those who
reach the Pinnacle of mystical Insight
in reality there is only God all else is
a kind of Illusion the world of other
than God is a report a story we are told
and tell ourselves which we give names
and attributes but its self-existence is
an illusion and there is really only God
these names and attributes the so-called
reports are there so that they can help
us reach the realization of God but once
we reach God's Essence is that or rather
once we realize God's Essence that is
always there we no longer need these
names and reports
sure study says quote therefore the one
who recognizes God by following the
authority of the asharis is a common
believer the one who recognizes him by
theological proofs and seeks proofs of
the Creator from things is an ashari
moreover the one who seeks proofs for
things by their creator is a Sufi and
the one who recognizes God through God
and sees none alongside God but God and
considers things to be non-existent is a
realizer again we are dealing with a
radical doctrine of Oneness which is why
it is called
absolute Unity
at the same time though he is careful to
neglect any claim that he follows some
sort of incarnationism there aren't two
different things or Essences God and the
world that are unified there is only God
and to claim that anything else exists
or is an agent is akin to polytheism or
shirk the greatest sin in Islam quote
thus there is nothing with God except
God in each thing nor is any part his
this is the true way of understanding
the Islamic religion and its scriptures
according to shushtari
and they trace this mystical knowledge
to many of their predecessors
very interestingly in his poem called
the nunia the poem rhyming in the letter
noon sure study lists all of the
spiritual predecessors including IBN
sabahin IBN Arabi
ibnifari and even extends it beyond the
Islamic world to figures like Plato and
Hermes
in other words shushtari sees himself as
representing a long-standing mystical
philosophical tradition which
encompasses all of these different
Masters but few of them of course would
Express themselves in such radically
monistic ways as shustadi as for example
when he says quote
for the realizers there is no arrival at
God since a rival implies an
in-betweenness prior to arrival yet God
is closer than a rival separation Union
difference proximity fairness mental or
spatial difference all of which are
attributes of bodies
a sure study remained a traveling fakir
a poor man for basically all of his life
he traveled all around North Africa and
Al andalus and eventually much like
others of his kin made his way to the
east
towards the end of his life a sure study
basically settled in Cairo Egypt but
continued to travel including to Mecca
several times where his master IBN
sabayin lived
indeed shustadi led the group of IBN
sabayin's followers in Egypt and here
became a very famous and renowned poet
and Sufi Master his last years are a bit
of a question mark
it seems that his followers preferred
him to his more difficult Master IBN
sabahin and that they started to refer
to themselves as the shushdariya rather
than the sabinea almost like a Sufi
order is centered around him the
biographies say that his followers
numbered at over 400 people which is
pretty respectable indeed interestingly
though it does seem relatively certain
that shushtadi and his followers joined
the shadowy order at some point at the
end of his life perhaps they had met
that order as founder Abu Hassan and his
disciples when they visited Egypt this
seems to be confirmed and shushed at his
own poetry where he writes quote my
masters they are shadowy in loving them
my heart Finds Its pleasure
I agree with the scholar Joseph casswood
here though that this does not mean that
srishta abandoned IBN sabahin or his his
teachings as some later Chronicles seem
to believe this is probably a way to
distance the rather well-liked and
popular shoe study from his
sometimes very controversial Mastery in
sabahin it seems likely that srishtari
remained devoted to his Mastery even
sabahin and his teachings for the rest
of his life even though his his
followers and and his sort of order were
was eventually sort of absorbed into the
larger shadly order which became one of
the largest Sufi orders in the world and
still is to this day Abu Hassani passed
away in the year 1269 in Egypt and was
first buried in damieta but was later
moved to Cairo where his grave still
stands today
he became remembered as an accomplished
and beloved albeit somewhat
controversial Sufi master who held ideas
of radical monism which made some other
Scholars pretty nervous but regardless
of how interesting the man himself is
and he truly is very interesting he is
after all primarily remembered and
famous as a magnificent poet and it is
in the realm of Arabic poetry and Arabic
Sufi poetry in particular that he left
his biggest Mark being highly educated
in al-andalous had a Mastery of the
classical forms of Arabic poetry and
wrote many poems in these classical
forms genres like the caseda or monorium
perhaps the most widely used and popular
of Sufi poetry in Arabic as well as the
appraisal the quatrains and many other
forms but it isn't necessarily these
poems that he became most famous for or
which are the most significant
historically
instead a shushtari was one of the first
to adopt local and the Lucian dialects
and poetic forms into his Sufi verse so
for those who don't know Arabic is often
divided into classical Arabic sometimes
called al-fusra and dialectical Arabic
in the Arab world which is obviously
very large the language itself is spoken
in a huge amount of different local
dialects and variants to the degree that
a person from Iraq often has a hard time
understanding someone in Morocco even
though they both supposedly speak Arabic
and this has been the case historically
too
classical Arabic or fusha serves as a
kind of official Standard Arabic this is
the Arabic used in the Quran based on
the Quran and used in official context
many Arabic speakers learned in school
and have varying degrees of
understanding of it but no one really
uses it as an everyday language the Sufi
poetry of the Middle Ages was written
almost exclusively In classical Arabic
as it was seen as the proper way to
express religious sentiment other
languages like Persian had become more
accepted as a secondary language for
poetry whereas Arabic was at least
According to some supposed to be kept in
this sort of sophisticated classical
form when it came to poetry
most of the famous poets like ibnel
faded and IBN Arabi all wrote their
poetry in classical Arabic almost
exclusively but by the later Middle Ages
this Norm was starting to be challenged
by some
in al-andalus there it started to appear
new forms of poetry that broke with the
classical magical forms a new genre
called moasha appeared and quickly
became very popular it had a much more
complex trophic form than the classical
monorium for example which could lead to
more creativity
mawasha was for the most part still
written in classical language however
but this cannot be said about another
new genre of poetry called the zajal a
kind of popular song in dialectical
language
was maybe the first or at least
certainly one of the first to adopt both
the moasha and zajal forms into his Sufi
poetry and songs there is a huge level
of experimentation in his verse often
combining different forms in the same
poem so for example he composed some
Russia poems that were primarily In
classical Arabic but suddenly used
vernacular language for the the refrain
only for example so shushali's poetry is
endlessly fascinating and very playful
which is one of the joyous of reading it
especially in his religious songs the
zajal the language and imagery is often
very simple playful and yet incredibly
profound this stands in contrast to his
more classical poems which often include
references to more abstract theosophical
ideas and language so his sajal his his
for his songs
um are often a lot more simple and and
Direct in their expression which is the
sort of resulted in the fact that they
became very popular among the masses
whereas the more classical forms of
poetry
required of sometimes a certain level of
understanding and education and
knowledge of Sufi metaphysics perhaps
and and poetic metaphors and so on to
even understand what he's saying that's
not necessarily the case for his zajal
songs for instance which is a lot more
clear and simpler right but still as I
said incredibly profound but there's a
reason for all this not all of which are
simply linguistic as we saw a shift
study throughout his life remained
dedicated to extreme voluntary poverty
and asceticism as an essential form of
Sufi practice
to him it was the only way to properly
fight and Conquer your nafs or ego your
yourself which is ultimately an illusion
quote I clothed my body in cords and
needles bits of discarded wool I beg a
bit of bread
we mentioned the concept of tajirid
which means to strip away and this is a
recurring theme in his writings too this
means to strip away all superficial
attachments and identities to the world
in order to reach intimacy with God in
one poem he says quote
um
there is no one in richness like you and
in poverty there are none like us we see
you manifest in everything nothing is
ours
srishtari's extreme asceticism is
relatively unusual for the sufis as many
of them still held it as an ideal to
remain in society and start a family for
example however would remain traveling
around as a fakir a poor man for the
rest of his life
he often had a very hostile attitude
towards any kind of powerful people
especially Kings or Sultans or the
Islamic jurists who would bow to them in
fact in one of his poems he writes quote
whoever bows before a vizier or Sultan
he is the Arrogant one yes he is
confused His Garment suits him for it is
imprinted with covetousness
as an extension of this he was also
significantly dedicated to when
concerned with the poor and the lower
classes of society and obviously he also
voluntarily belonged to that class of
society
poor people were in a Superior State to
those who weren't whether or not that
poverty is voluntary or not
quote the poor man is outstanding
whether he renounced the World by choice
or by necessity
this dedication to the lower classes of
society is key to understanding the
purpose of his songs and poems why he
wrote them in the vernacular language
and his whole way of practicing Sufism
it is said that shushtari would
frequently either on instruction by his
masterib in sabahin or not wander around
the local souks or marketplaces what the
scholar Lords Maria Alvarez calls the
medieval equivalent of the red light
district he would go to these souks
dressed in rags and sing his mystical
songs perhaps accompanied by Companions
and musical instruments by many this
would be seen as scandalous as these
environments were associated with
taverns prostitutes and the quote
illiterate masses of men clearly this
was both a spiritual practice for
sristari but also a strong message to
the jurists The Sultans the conformist
sufis and educated Elite who looked with
the spice on this world of the
marketplace
sure study instead despised their
hypocrisy their greediness and the
abandonment of poverty by many sufis and
this can be said to characterize
srishtari's entire life and his entire
message in a way both in actions like
here and in his poetry itself he always
takes the side of the uneducated of the
poor the everyday person and strongly
criticizes the rule-obsessed
hypocritical jurist or fukaha the greedy
Sultans and the elite of Lema it thus
becomes clear why he was so adamant to
compose his religious songs and poetry
in a dialectical language his audience
was the people of the marketplace his
audience was the poor his audience were
those who didn't have the education of
classical Arabic poetry or the abstract
metaphysical language and metaphors that
were often used therein
instead he composed light-hearted songs
with a strong emphasis on emotion but
that still carry the mystical religious
message that he considered to be the
true expression of the Islamic faith
mysticism was of course a celebration of
the Divine but it was no less a
multiform descent a protest against the
hypocrisy and spiritual emptiness of the
Islam practiced and promoted by the
fukaha and the ullama in the service of
temporal rulers and against those who
appointed themselves judges of the piety
of others poetry and song thus were far
more than a means of personal mystical
expression they were a tool for
recruiting Sufi adapts to a movement
whose call for ecstatic religious
renewal deeply threatened the power of
the jurists and imams indeed jurists at
the time and since then have been very
skeptical and critical of sushtari and
sufis like him they were to some degree
afraid that they these strange Sufi
Figures were attracting the masses and
thus compromising their own authority
which of course in a lot of cases they
actually were and as we've seen this was
kind of exactly what truth daddy wanted
his poetry and songs have become very
important for spreading this kind of
Sufi message to to the general masses or
attracting people through his
lighthearted songs and beautiful
Melodies but the jurists and later
critics were not only skeptical of Sri
study because he was very attractive and
that he to some degree undermine their
Authority they were also very much
concerned with the philosophical and
metaphysical mystical doctrines and
ideas that he was expressing in that
poetry those ideas Associated for
example with his master IBN sabaim now
we should be careful not to view this
situation in the commonly misunderstood
way that there is some kind of clear
dichotomy between sufis on the one hand
and Orthodox Muslims on the other this
is a very common misunderstanding that
needs to be nuanced for most of History
these Scholars or Lema and Islamic
jurists were also sufis there didn't
exist this clear line between sufis and
Orthodox Muslims this is mostly a modern
Construction
the two categories go together most of
the time and shush that his critiques of
the fukaha or the jurist should not be
read as a condemnation of all jurists or
of jurisprudence at large instead sure
study is critical of a certain kind of
Muslim scholar the rigid jurist who is
only concerned without a ritual and who
critique others for not following their
narrow understanding of the law
they follow a shallow form of Islam
emptied of all inner meaning and
spiritual content which is what is
criticizing this should be kept in mind
as we go forward so that we don't fall
into simplistic and inaccurate
dichotomizing in any case his connection
with his master IBN sabahin and his
doctrine of absolute Unity
is the source of most attacks on the
poet and it wasn't always so much the
philosophy itself that was the problem
but the very fact that he was spreading
these complex esoteric ideas to the
masses who had no education in theology
or philosophy in this way many saw him
as even more dangerous than his master
IBN sabahin as the latter only appealed
to the elite through his abstract
philosophical text whereas schusteri of
course were very attractive was very
attracted to the masses because he
talked to them through very simple songs
and and beautiful poetry as sure study
expresses the ideas associated with
in many of his poems and songs it's
characterized by a view where God is the
only reality which can be experienced
everywhere at all times
in his poems he often breaks the barrier
between Creator and creation between the
one and the many where God is and where
he isn't God is all there is and all
else is illusion and vanity
quotes
foreign
what is your beloved's name I said him
there is no confusing the name of the
Beloved just understand me just
understand me
my beloved encompasses all existence he
is visible in white and black and in
Christian and Jew
and in the letters and their points just
understand me just understand me
in the plants and in the minerals in
black and in white in the pen and the
ink
his poems are frequently concerned with
witnessing God everywhere and with the
process of stripping bear one's
self-identity until one's ego or nephs
any sense of separate self whatsoever is
completely annihilated and only the
reality of God remains this Annihilation
is known in Sufi terms as fanaa the
complete annihilation of the South and a
union with God or rather a realization
of the fact that God was once true
Essence all along at least according to
the philosophy of study in many of his
poems similar to other sufis he uses
metaphors from common secular poetry and
gives them new spiritual meanings one of
the most common of these metaphors is to
express the experience of
self-annihilation or fanaa through wine
and intoxication as in the following
poem quote
foreign
I drink wine from the goblets and from
myself I come closer to myself
in myself it is myself I love
notice here how he plays with the
pronoun for I to completely collapse the
distinction between the seeker and the
sought between the lover and the Beloved
as a full expression of divine unity and
Oneness
a similar creative tendency can be found
in this poem quote
foreign
it is you who speak and you who listen
just when do you think what is absent
will appear
God is the one with no other
there is nothing like me I am one
and the Very notion of place in truth is
trouble
when you let go of awareness you will
find us
again he's very playfully here using
different pronouns to express the
ineffable experience of the unit of
Consciousness where one realizes the
Oneness of being in this state of being
you I and even us are all used seemingly
to designate the same reality at other
times he's even more explicit in his
language quote for he is my Essence my
true soul
I seek in myself what I already have
I am everything the center of totality
except this
or quote creation is your creation and
all Affairs are your Affairs for what am
I not even ruins
I speak the truth there is nothing in
the universe but is not you
I seek refuge in God from my knowledge
and acts
you show yourself to yourself in
yourself
continuity which bespeaks the Enigma of
Eternity
or even still quote indeed I am quite
aside for whomever might see me I am the
lover and the Beloved there is nothing
else
Seeker the heart of the matter is
cloaked by your eye itself
return to your essence and Proclaim
there is nothing outside of you
in these popular songs and poems these
unitive experiences aren't explained
using complex metaphysical Concepts but
in simple language despite its
Simplicity it is often as you can see
very beautiful and profound
the implications of these monistic
Tendencies and their spread to the
uneducated masses scared many of the
jurists and olama which probably made
sure study very happy they not only
criticized ideas and his poems but also
some of the practices that he would
partake in as part of his Sufi practice
in particular
aspects that would be criticized are the
the wearing of the patched cloak the the
cloak of poverty which some sufis would
wear as well as the practice of gazing
upon beautiful faces as a spiritual
practice and just in general questioning
the Conformity of the sufis to the
Sunnah of the Prophet Muhammad many of
his prose works such as the result
are dedicated to defending these Sufi
practices from its critics and show that
they are completely in line with the
Sunnah of the prophet and Islamic law in
the Baghdad Judas a shushtari responds
to many of these critiques and in turn
attacks the he views the practice of
gazing upon beautiful faces as entirely
Justified and even extends this notion
in a very beautiful section he explains
how praising God is not simply done
through speech but through all of the
senses quote
gazing upon the countenance is to gaze
upon the countenance or head or hair of
a poor man or Rich Man or in general
upon animals plants and matter
listening is veneration speech is
veneration as long as what is said is
good sensory experience is veneration
all five senses if one recognizes that
God encompasses all of existence every
sensory experience can become an Act of
veneration or prayer every word said
every sight one sees every piece of
music one listens to is an act of prayer
and devotion for those who have the eye
to see God present everywhere at all
times furthermore he argues using
hadiths and other sources that other
practices of the sufis are perfectly in
line with the Sunnah but also extends a
general critique against a jurist and
their understanding of the Sunnah itself
to ashishtari many of the fukaha or
jurists follow a shallow Dead version of
Islam one that is obsessed with rules
and where the jurists or Scholars often
take on the role as judges of other
people's piety or behavior he not only
sees this as hypocritical but foolish
and ignorant in the Baghdad treatis he
very cleverly points out quote for every
member of the community claims that he
is correctly practicing Sunnah and that
others are duped by innovation
thus as sure study can be said to
represent a relative Dog Channel
openness in this sense never neglecting
the Sunnah the prophet or Islamic law
those are still very important to him of
course and to in this practice but
instead a stronger emphasis on personal
experience right the inner personal
experience and intimacy and relationship
with God in that sense as well as the
spread of those ideas to the masses
rather than focusing on getting bogged
down in formalities and the hypocritical
ideas of the worldly sort of greedy
jurists and Scholars Abu Hassani is
certainly a champion of the general
population
a Sufi poet of the people whose ecstatic
expressions of the Oneness of reality
reaches us to this day with its haunting
Beauty and distinct social message he
used songs and music in Sufi context
often called Sama not just as a personal
or internal Sufi practice but as a way
to extend its reach to as many people as
possible
quote
foreign
when I went towards my object and
listened to the music my misery became
glory and my poverty riches
this and his use of local forms of song
and poetry in the mawasha and zajal
forms and of course the vernacular
language that he used was kind of a
revolution at the time that strongly
affected Sufism in the region and abroad
the popularity of these forms of poetry
and songs in Sufi Sama sessions in North
Africa to this day can to a significant
degree be attributed to a Schuster's
influence indeed the practice of sama or
of listening to music as a significant
spiritual practice has been very common
in Sufism across history and shushday
represents a significant example of that
his poems were often songs Meant To Be
Sung with musical accompaniment and we
saw that he and his followers would
indeed perform these songs publicly on
occasion and this connection continued
later in history all the way until today
as his poems are very commonly sung in
samah sessions in the region especially
in the shadowy order to which his
followers became basically assimilated
indeed the famous 14th century shadowy
Sufi IBN Abad of Ronda writes that he
loves shishtari's poems and that they
elicit very strong emotions in him quote
especially if they are accompanied by
music and beautiful voices
which indicates that this was a common
Trend even shortly after sure study
himself lived he isn't a figure that is
too well known in the larger world but
he has become somewhat of a local hero
in Western North Africa in countries
like Morocco Algeria and Tunisia his
songs are still sung today at Sufi
Gatherings they are played on the radio
when recorded as music albums
certainly then sistari's mission of
spreading his message through popular
forms is still very much working today
I think this ideal is finally expressed
in one of his poems quotes appearances
are a delusion rise to the fore the
science are in you to come near the king
diminish yourself my sweetest moments
are when I am one with my essence
apply your intellect to what is rational
the proof leads you to the proven you
will see the bearer is what is born
say this is a mistake would be a mistake
music allows me to speak to the people
my sweetest moments are when I am one
with my essence
I'll see you next time
[Music]
thank you